[Music]
well with covet cases on the rise the
nevada gaming control board is
tightening up on the mask mandate the
goal is to keep people safe as they ring
in the new year mary jane bellissa
joining us live now on the strip with
how it will all be enforced mary jane
yeah well christian the nevada gaming
control board is reminding hotels and
casinos to stay in compliance with
governor sislek's mass mandate or else
face fines now if you're in one of the
properties behind me and you're not
wearing a mask be prepared to be asked
to put it on now if you're outside it is
optional
i think it will be more people saying
toward the mask there are a few that
they are not doing it claudia lives in
the valley and has seen and heard about
the complaints of visitors not complying
with the mask mandate she says while
people mostly wear their mask inside
some will not but i have seen like
employees telling them like hey wear
your mask even one time i forget it and
they say me hey you're mad and i was
like oh and others like allison is
frustrated about the mandate i think
everyone's wearing them i think everyone
just doesn't want to i think it's
infringing on our rights and
people in america have had people that
died for our rights so i think we're all
over the map the mask mandate indoors is
required regardless of vaccination
status the gaming control board not only
can find gaming establishments but they
can revoke a license
now as for fines to tell you how serious
it can be for a gaming property the last
enforcement against the las vegas casino
involved a 60 thousand dollar fine now
that was against the mohegan sun casino
at virgin hotels in las vegas after it
opened of march of 2021 reporting at the
strip mary jane bellezza live local now